something you brought up before that we
won't have time to cover today but it's
fascinating is
is entrepreneurs are
a really unique uh
group of humans and in fact
entrepreneurs have
more in common with each other than most
uh ethnicities races i mean if you look
at
the traits that cut across all
entrepreneurs right it's a
it's a really interesting study that you
know
and there's a guy that i'm working with
um i'm volunteering
to help uh with a company called akana
and it's it's uh i'm an advisor but
again i have no financial affiliation
and this guy michael freeman has done
probably the most
research on entrepreneurship and mental
health and he has written
extensively about the character traits
the
mental health issues that are really in
every entrepreneur and
and that you may sidestep it through
your process but
eventually most entrepreneurs are
triggered and this
and the these conditions that are in
them are brought out
and instead of hiding from we should
just embrace it and in some cases like
you look at someone like um howard
hughes right
he he had many mental health issues yes
he was wildly successful
and so understanding how to
that was my question too before the
break when i had said you know
founders do people with you know
uh mental conditions mental uniqueness
get drawn to entrepreneurship or does
entrepreneurship
actually drive people to mental
conditions or illness what are your
thoughts there
and what are the traits either direction
in terms of causing correlation
so about half this is kind of science
not not my
conjecture about um half
of the conditions that
entrepreneurs experience as
entrepreneurs are genetic
like half so half of the influence on
their
mental health is genetic so i would say
that really they're drawn
there's a certain kind of person that's
drawn to entrepreneurship
somebody with something to prove
somebody
um who has leadership or narcissism
or asperger's you know like i mean
we see so many archetypes adhd for sure
because you get to bounce around as the
ceo
right from the sales department to the
product department to the customer
support department to investors to press
i mean right
that it is definitely adhd addd seems
like a superpower
but then dyslexia i mean look at our
governor's dyslexic you're dyslexic
there's a way you've had to compensate
for your dyslexia that that has made
that is probably in there as part of
what has made you
the mix of success it's definitely in
the mix yeah well you know what i think
also it's humbling for me um
to mispronounce words sometimes and then
have to study harder
and right then people read my book and
they go that's one of the best business
books i ever read
and i'm like how did i get there you
know
i realized what it was was i i figured
out a writing style that worked for me
which was i wasn't trying to emulate
anybody else's
writing style i just had heard that
somebody said
um write down what you say and so then i
started recording
conversations that i would have in fact
the podcast and then i would transcribe
it and then i would use that as the
framework for when i would write
something and then people say i hear my
i hear your voice in your blog posts
and it's like the reason you hear my
voice in my blog posts
is because i transcribed my voice and
then polished that
that's really smart it was just like oh
well it was just like you
and this is one of the things where the
the super power you can turn
any i believe turn any of these things
into a super power aspergers people
can't make eye contact who can focus
and they're at dinner and you're like uh
hello where are you
and you know they're just off in space
solving some math problem while
everybody else is talking
and you're like yeah that's my friend
blank and the other friend blank
and this other principal how many people
do we know i mean do we know who are on
the spectrum and even
i i think you know like inappropriately
like you know like they make fun of
zuckerberg for being on the spectrum on
saturday night live it's a little bit
cruel
i think yes um and and
whether it's accurate or not and it
likely is but
it's a little bit cruel um he was born
that i mean he was born that way
whatever
you know whatever you know here's one
stat that's kind of fascinating and
this is what what you're doing and what
the show is doing we're all trying to do
is
shine a light on on these conditions
because
it allows us to meet the these talented
entrepreneurs where they are
versus trying to force them to be
something they're not and so
you know this way this statistic i'm
looking at it now i i found it today
38 of entrepreneurs have have have
reported a diagnosable mental health
condition
that includes depression adhd bipolar
anxiety
and addiction right so 38
of entrepreneurs you and you the
addiction part we see all the time like
you watch all these vcs going up and
down santora road on those road bikes
and they become mental right taking
their bikes and riding to
stinson beach and back in tahoe and then
they become triathletes it's almost
comical
that the addiction can apply to
you know kite surfing like how many of
our friends do we see become
addicted to kite surfing and they can't
stop right and you're like
you know you have you are the co-founder
of google you're gonna need to get off
the kite board at some point and get
back to the office you know
and like it's the addiction i mean
thankfully it's not drugs or alcohol
which are you know negative addictions
but if you get addicted to kiteboarding
or
whatever you want to ski 30 days a year
like
not a problem like a healthy channeling
like you're saying